president trump addressed cpac over the
weekend this was his first
public appearance since leaving the
white house
and president trump took on rumors head
on that he was going to start a new
political party to challenge the
republican party
trump said that was a bunch of fake news
he doesn't need to start a new party
because he already runs one of the major
parties in this country
we will do what we've done right from
the beginning which is to win
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party it's going
to unite and be stronger than ever
before
i am not starting a new party
that was fake news fake news no
wouldn't that be brilliant let's start a
new party and let's divide our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that
no they're not interested in that
whatsoever in the trump world because as
the cpac straw poll shows
trump is still dominating the republican
party i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from cardi
o who says in honor of their employees
completing the critical race theory
training
coca-cola has come out with a new flavor
less
vanilla coke that's really progressive
of them i'm so glad that they are doing
that
there is actually an update to the woca
cola story
it's great stuff some might call it
cancel culture i call it absolutely a-ok
in my book
you can listen to that just a little bit
later in the show and when you listen i
highly recommend you listen
on raycon wireless earbuds whether
you're catching up on your favorite news
podcast
binging an audio book or powering
through your workout with a pumped up
playlist a pair of raycons in your ears
can make all the difference no dangling
wires or stems to get in the way
raycons come in a range of stylish
colorways
they're always comfortable they've got a
great in-ear fit it's a more discreet
look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs quickly and seamlessly it's
also got enough battery life for six
hours of play time
which means you can unplug for a while
i've tried
lots of the competition i'm just here to
tell you raycon's is a superior product
in looks
in functionality it's great and
especially in price because they're not
overpriced like some of the competitors
and right now on top of that raycon's is
offering 15 off all their products from
my listeners
here's what you got to do to get it go
to byracon.com knowles that's it
you'll get 15 off your entire raikon
order so feel free to grab a pair and a
spare
that's 15 off at buy raycon.com knowles
buy raycon.com
knowles go check out raycon now
president trump is back he is
demonstrating in his words
and in public opinion polls that
the gop is still the trump party and cnn
is ecstatically furious
this cpac with donald trump closing it
out is a liar palooza
uh it's a liar palooza zing yeah
take that trump yeah you're a big meanie
yeah it's a
liar festa this was the best day that
jim acosta has had in months jim acosta
has gone to his bed every single night
since trump
conceded the election and he's written
dear diary
it's another it's another sad day here
in the acosta household
i miss him i have nothing to talk about
no one wants to put me on television
anymore no one gives me headlines
because my man is gone well trump is
back
and the media are are furious
so trump's cpac speech was generally
more measured than some people said it
would be and some people said he was
going to announce a new political party
some people said he was going to declare
himself the nominee for 2024 some people
said he was going to do all this
it was actually much more measured he
he reigned himself in a little bit but
he still talked about the important
issues
starting most importantly with election
integrity
another one of the most urgent issues
facing the republican party
is that of ensuring fair honest
and secure elections
such a disgrace we must pass
comprehensive election reforms and we
must do it now the democrats use the
china virus
as an excuse to change all of the
election rules without the approval of
their state legislatures
making it therefore illegal
it had a massive impact on the election
again you have to go to the legislatures
to get these approvals
this alone would have easily changed the
outcome of the election
at levels that you wouldn't have even
believed
now people are going to be very upset
trump is pushing a lie about the
election show me the lie
where's the lie the democratic election
officials
exploited the china virus to upend the
election systems in the weeks and months
before the election often without
the approval of state legislatures in
some cases in direct violation
of the state constitutions so
show me the lie i don't see a lie there
but then notice what trump says he
doesn't say and that's why we actually
won the election and biden 100
actually lost he didn't say that he said
it had a massive
impact on the election which is true you
you can at least say even if you think
that
the whole rigging of the election
systems was illegitimate and terrible
you still can't say for with 100
certainty trump won the election you
know and
the votes that were fraudulent were
enough to sway the election
no one actually can say that people
might have a hunch they might have an
intuition
but you can't but you certainly can say
that
these election rules were upended in the
days and months right before the
election
and this did have an impact on the of
course you can say that
so trump holds himself there to me what
this means is
trump does not want to go out with a you
know
huge bang he doesn't want to go out you
know with fireworks
he wants to remain in the game and he's
willing to play in a certain sense by
the rules
so that he can have a big influence in
2022 and who knows
maybe 2024. trump also
in we'll get to 2024 in a second in
terms of 2022
he named names he went after
the squishy republicans who he feels are
not
standing up for what the republican base
wants he didn't back off that he
this is another reason he's not just
playing nice and trying to have a nice
legacy here
he is calling out the people that he
wants to boot out of office as soon as
he can
now more than ever is the time for tough
strong and energetic
republican leaders who have spines of
steel we need strong leadership
top establishment republicans in
washington
should be spending their energy in
opposing biden pelosi schumer
and the democrats i've said to some of
them i said you know
during the obama years and now during
biden
if you spent the same energy on
attacking them you'd actually be
successful
as you do on attacking me in many cases
the democrats don't have grandstanders
like mitt romney
little ben sass richard burr bill
cassidy susan collins
lisa murkowski pat toomey david
valadeo and of course the war monger
a person that loves seeing our troops
fighting
liz cheney how about that
the good news is in her state she's been
censured and in her state
her poll numbers have dropped faster
than any human being i've ever seen
this is donald trump's party i say that
not just as someone who likes trump
when i when i say this is donald trump's
party i'm sort of pleased
that i can say that but even people who
hate
trump's guts even romney and liz cheney
and all the rest of them
have to admit this is trump's party mitt
romney did admit it the other day he
said
i mitt romney represent a very small
sliver of the republican party donald
trump would win the nomination in a
landslide if he ran
how strange is it that at cpac this is
sort of the big
conservative conference of the year
the chairman of the house republican
caucus liz
cheney gets booed overwhelmingly booed
on the floor like that
mitt romney who won the cpac straw poll
in 2012
mitt romney who used to be pretty
popular at cpac getting booed
because the party is shifting and
because politics
always does change it changes according
to circumstance so that's 2022
obviously i think trump is going to try
to pick off some of his political
opponents
but what about 2024 if trump's got the
party behind him if trump's got the
conservative base behind him
if trump's picking off his opponents is
he going to run in 2024
well he doesn't say no but who knows
who knows i may even decide
to beat them for a third time okay
that is a long long long round of
applause and standing ovation and trump
does it in the most trumpian way
with such a showman's flourish she goes
and look i may even you're kind of
leaning in look i might even
decide to beat him for a third time boom
and then the crowd
opens up and when he says beat him for a
third time he's obviously suggesting
this is this is the most i think trump
in his speech went to say
that election you know a lot of
irregularities a lot of irregularities
there
uh the the cpac straw poll is pretty
interesting
because in terms of the candidates trump
wins
he walks away with it he he got the
majority of votes
in a field of uh trump desantis gnome
haley pompeo
trump gets 55 percent in the cpac straw
poll
so even if all those other candidates
were just one other candidate
trump still wins uh desantis
no surprise there that he's coming up
second by a lot too it's 55
to 21 for desantis then when you get to
christy gnome
it's four percent nikki haley three
percent mike pompeo two percent
not really surprising numbers when you
take a look at the struggle without
trump so let's say trump decides not to
run
ron de santa is still crushing it he's
got 43 percent up there
christy nomen 11 don jr at eight percent
again just evidence that the trump
family is dominating the party even
don jr right who was not the president
still doing pretty well
pompeo seven percent cruise seven
percent the the one thing
worth noting here is that
the straw poll has a kind of 50 50
record so the straw poll was right about
the nominee in
uh 1980 and then obviously right in 1984
they probably shouldn't even held it
that year but reagan got it again in 84.
they were right in 96 2000 and 2012. but
the cpac straw poll got the nominee
wrong
in 76 92 2008 and 2016.
trump trump did not come in first or
even second in 2016.
so these things can change quite a lot
the other thing i would say about ron
desantis he's doing a great job he's
doing everything he should be doing
um but it's a long time it's a long time
away from 2024
the the people who tend to win this
early historically have not
actually gotten the nomination later on
so we'll have to see more interesting
even than the candidates are the issues
the top issue for the cpac audience
election integrity followed by
constitutional rights followed by
immigration followed by reopening the
economy was pretty low on the list
followed by the second amendment
followed by taxes followed by national
security
finally followed by pro-life pretty
interesting i don't think it's because
the
cpac crowd is pro-abortion now i suspect
it's just because
they feel that we're at a stalemate and
no matter how many judges we get we
still keep
losing they the issue here is the
corruption they feel we keep winning
these political battles but we keep
losing on these issues
so that's actually my read of why
pro-life is so down low it's people are
very demoralized
and i think it's why election integrity
is so high because they do not have
faith
in this system they don't really have
the sort of faith in the institutions
that we once had you've got to root out
the corruption before you can solve
these sorts
of problems you know when when things
are kind of chaotic all around the world
one thing that i've always enjoyed
investing in precious metals
you know how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately now there's a new
way to buy gold through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to
gold bars for as little as thirty
dollars a month michael how is that
possible gold bars cost more than thirty
dollars well
it's this ingenious way to invest in
physical gold you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house
just recently acre has introduced a new
100 a month subscription
to a 5 gram gold bar also check this out
you know how there's a nationwide ammo
shortage well acre is creating a solid
gold 24 karat
9 millimeter bullet for you to buy right
now
you cannot find anything like this on
the internet they're only making a
thousand of these they're going very
fast and i definitely want one
uh to be clear i guess i have to say
this they're not shootable bullets
unless you're killing a werewolf
they are solid gold they're very very
cool go check it out i think this
company is really
changing the game i've always enjoyed
investing in precious metals visit
getacre gold.com
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for that giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
at get underscore acre that is getacre
gold.com
michael and thank you anchor gold for
supporting the show it is
trump's party the republican party it is
trump's party and
in part that's because of trump he is
this sort of uniquely talented
politician even his opponents admit this
even mitt romney admits that donald
trump just has
a political gift but there's another
reason too
another reason that the gop became
donald trump's party and has remained
donald trump's party
is because the left makes no distinction
between the moderates and the party or
the liberals in the party
and the conservatives and the super
conservatives
and the far right fringy people and the
kooky people
the left makes no distinction between
any of them
a classic example of this uh
congressman marie newman congressman
marie newman
is a democrat and uh
she has made transgender ideology one of
her central issues
uh this obviously very important with
the passage uh the passage in the house
not yet in the senate of the equality
act
the equality act obliterates the legal
distinction between men and women
it is the single most radical piece of
legislation
ever in american history it
it not not only
you know would sort of upend american
society it also removes specifically
legal protections for women
to have for instance their own sports
leagues to have their own bathrooms
their own changing rooms that that goes
away with the equality act
and marie newman very into this mourinho
actually put a transgender flag
you believe they have a flag it's a
transgender ideology flag outside of her
office
leading congressman marjorie taylor
greene
to put a sign outside of her office
which is right across the hallway which
says
there are two genders men and women and
marjorie taylor green is called the
conspiracy theorist for that
if you if you believe that men and women
are different you're you're the crazy
conspiracy theorist
if uh you if you don't you're a sort of
reasonable person
maureen newman goes on cnn and says that
the reason
that the republicans will not
attack marjorie taylor green for having
the sign out there that says men are
different than women
is that they are quote in fear of the q
anon
kooks the q anon kooks what is q anon i
suspect most people listening to this
show
don't really have any idea what q anon
is i don't really know what q anon is i
know i've like googled it a little bit i
sort of have some kind of idea
most republicans public opinion surveys
have
borne this out don't really have any
idea what this is most trump supporters
don't really have any idea what this
is it's just it's just a new term to
smear
the right they take some sort of minor
phenomenon they smear the right the same
way that they say the right they're
white supremacists you think
really i don't think so who are you
talking to on the right
but they're not just saying that these
very far fringe extreme people
are huge on kooks whatever that it just
means bad right that's
they're just using q anon or white
supremacist or whatever to mean
a bad person who's not a good person but
so okay it's not just the fringe that's
the q and on kooks
it's not just conspiracy theorists
they're not just
bigots it's not just it's not it's not
even just trump supporters
it's not even just conservatives it's
not even just the republican party
it's anybody who believes that men and
women are different
can you imagine that that is how broadly
the democrats are painting this and so
in that world
when everybody is being lumped in and
called the worst
possible names you need a tough guy you
need someone with spines of steel like
donald trump says and so i think
republicans and conservatives are
willing to make some concessions
yeah the tweets are a little mean or
whatever yeah
he sometimes speaks out of turn yeah he
sometimes says things that are
slight exaggerations yeah whatever
whatever
if you're in a world where the democrats
are trying to utterly delegitimize
anyone and not just even half the
country but people who think men and
women are different right you're talking
about the majority of the country i
should hope
if you if you're in that world where
common sense is not politically
permissible
you need a tough guy you need a guy with
spines of steel
so the the right does seem
a little bit divided right now between
kind of the trump faction
and the i don't call it the romney
faction or the more squishy faction
it seems a little bit divided trump
still has control of it for now but
there's a lot of acrimony
democrats are seeming divided now as
well i actually don't think they are
divided
but they give the appearance of it i
think actually republicans have a lot to
learn from this
case in point andrew cuomo andrew we
call him governor quovid in new york
you know that leadership genius from
covid19
you know the greatest most admirable
wonderful governor in america who was
just basically
throwing elderly new yorkers into
disease-ridden
nursing homes and then covering it up
when the fed started looking into it
so andrew cuomo separate from his actual
scandal
which is the the kovid stuff
he is being accused of sexual harassment
and it's all sort of vague but
there was one woman who came out and
said yeah you know a while ago cuomo
tried to kiss me at a meeting
or something now a second woman is
accusing him of sexual harassment
charlotte bennett worked as an assistant
of his
and then she left in november and she
said that the harassment began in the
spring
of 2020 and it's all kind of vague stuff
so it's
you know he brought up sex but not
she's not saying he propositioned her
necessarily she's not
she's not really bringing the context of
it sounds you know kind of inappropriate
but
it's really unclear
democrats are now coming out against
cuomo they're now saying yep
that guy is at l at the very least he
needs to be investigated
this from our favorite white house press
secretary
who is currently the press secretary
jens hockey
governor cuomo says he never made
advances toward miss bennett but
does president biden believe governor
cuomo or
charlotte bennett
well first president biden has been
consistent that he believes that
every woman should be heard should be
treated with respect and with dignity
charlotte should be treated with respect
and dignity so should lindsay and there
should be an independent
review looking into these allegations
and that's certainly something he
supports and we believe should move
forward as quickly as possible
nancy pelosi saying almost the same
thing the women who've come forward with
serious and credible charges so she's
calling it credible against governor
cuomo deserve to be heard and treated
with dignity
the independent investigation must have
due process and respect for everyone
involved
what's really going on here i don't
think that democrats have finally gotten
a conscience on
the sexual harassment claims or anything
like that i think what's really going on
is that there were claims like this
before against andrew cuomo and they
completely ignored them
and they actually promoted him and they
had him speak at their conference and
they said he was the greatest leader on
kovid19
then it it came out they finally
couldn't cover it up anymore
that his policies were deadly in covid19
and that he knew it and that he covered
them up against the federal government
so now just coincidentally just
coincidentally
when his political fortunes are dropping
and he's an embarrassment for the
democratic party
now all of a sudden they're taking the
sexual harassment stuff seriously
but it doesn't even stop there because
they're taking it seriously enough to
say he needs to be investigated
but this is what democrats do they're
not saying he needs to step down
they're not saying he's unfit for office
they're saying we need an investigation
they do the same thing on
reparations they do the same thing on
all sorts of
radical policies that they're proposing
they say we need to commit they do this
on statute toppling they say
we need a committee to study and review
the issue and they basically they slow
walk it to buy themselves time and build
themselves political consensus
so what's going to happen now because
cuomo is really really in a
hot water because of his mishandling of
kovid
and his cover-up of of the covet issue
is they're going to say okay we're going
to start threatening you we're going to
start building consensus
so if we have to deal with you we're
going to deal with you we're also
coincidentally going to get covered out
of the news because everyone's just
talking about your sex scandal
and then we're going to buy ourselves
time and then once
the investigation is over in six months
if you're still in trouble we'll boot
you out
if you're an embarrassment for us but if
you're not in trouble we'll let you come
back in no big deal
it's politically brilliant and cuomo by
the way is handling this in a pretty
smart political way too
cuomo came out and sort of apologized
and sort of didn't here's his excuse
it's a master class in political
rhetoric
he says questions have been no i'm not
going to do my bulldog formal impression
questions have been raised about some of
my past interactions with people in the
office
i never intended to offend anyone or
cause any harm i spend most of my life
at work and colleagues are often
also personal friends at work sometimes
i think i'm being playful and make jokes
that i think are funny
i do on occasion tease people in what i
think is a good-natured way
i do it in public and in private you
have seen me do it at briefings hundreds
of times
i have teased people about their
personal lives their relationships about
getting married or not getting married
wow wow man is this good he doesn't
take on the allegation that he tried to
kiss somebody during a meeting he
doesn't take on the allegation that he's
moved
i mean eventually he just sort of denies
the idea that he's propositioning people
and denying it but that's not what he's
saying here he's admitting yeah i tease
people
he says i do it in public and private
you've seen me do it right he's making
you
sort of accustomed to it you're saying
oh i have seen that it's not it's a
beautiful
politically beautiful way to downplay
this sort of thing
and uh he'll it'll probably help him
because
when we're talking about that we're not
talking about
the other allegations we're not talking
about the real scandal not the sex
sex scandal is the best thing that ever
happened to andrew cuomo because we're
not talking about his kovitz scandal
right now
and we feel a little bit more
comfortable with it
the democrats are just much much better
at this sort of thing
than the conservatives are ben is going
to be talking about this very issue the
end
for cuomo on his show today so be sure
to check that out also you got to check
out
ben shapiro in the daily wires newest
series debunked
every friday ben is exposing popular
fallacies
supported by left-wing activists and
politicians
in the first episode which is now
available to daily wire members
ben debunks the myth of minimum wage i
got to go check that out the myth of
minimum wage debunked is
also available exclusively to daily wire
members so go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership and stay tuned
for this friday's episode where ben will
break down
unions that is code debunked for 25
off we'll be right back with a lot more
cuomo is not the only democratic
governor in trouble right now
gavin newsom is also in trouble gavin
newsom is
governor patrick bateman from california
governor american psycho over there in
my old state
and when i say they're in trouble yes
they're in trouble but
not nearly the sort of trouble they'd be
in if they were republicans and maybe
not
politically terminal trouble you know
maybe they'll be able to survive this
what they really do i find they just
flaunt their power
so gavin newsom got in trouble a few
months ago
because he ordered all these lockdown
rules and his mandates and shutting down
businesses and restaurants then what
does he do
he shows up with his friends to the
french laundry
a michelin rated restaurant these
meals that for the french laundry are
often thousand dollars a plate sometimes
more
he shows up he's sitting right next to
his friends looked pretty indoors to me
shoulder to shoulder no one's wearing
masks and they're all laughing and
having a good time and they're all
laughing at us because we believe the
kind of nonsense that they're spouting
about how we need to stay home and
social distance and all that
stuff that they themselves are not are
not following
so newsome got in trouble for that but
he survived now he posted another video
with george lopez the
sitcom star from the 2000s you know he
kind of
now all he does is really turn up in
political videos
and he's he's inside a restaurant with
george lopez they're wearing masks
but they're inside a restaurant in an
area that is supposed to have
closed no indoor dining
how do i find out if i can get a
vaccination
george you got to go to my turn.ca.gov
wait a minute thank you governor
it's wonderful to be a surface george
first of all just 100 pure
grade a cringe in the video right i mean
that's that is so
they're like hello hey fellow tick
talkers hello
how do you do fellow kids uh but beyond
that
what are they doing in that restaurant
what are they doing they're not supposed
to be in that restaurant in that county
in that area
so they're inside there well maybe
they're just there for a film shoot
right
well they were they were sort of posting
some pictures it looks like they had
some food there
i actually the way i know they had some
food there is because when you film
anything
you have craft services so that the crew
and cast members can eat
so you got new sim again i think it is
not
unfair to infer
he's certainly inside a restaurant so
he's already breaking that rule and i
suspect
they might have had a bite or two to eat
i suspect that's what the photos sort of
suggest they just flaunt their power and
they know
that they're gonna not get into any
trouble for this speaking of the virus
by the way
some good news sort of sort of i guess
it's good news but it's kind of
frustrating
it's frustrating because we we don't
know who to trust anymore
the medical experts who've told us that
the mitigation efforts for coronavirus
they've failed
we still we're not wearing our masks
enough we're not locking down enough
we're not social distancing enough
that's why the virus is spreading that's
why we got to keep locking down
if only you rubes had locked down for
two weeks we would have slowed the
spread in 15 days now we're going on 350
days
so they tell us no that works but then
we're also told
the flu has basically disappeared flu
season
peaks between december and february the
cdc estimates that flu causes
up to 45 million illnesses each year
up to 810 000 hospitalizations and up to
61
000 deaths
how many flu cases i'm not talking about
deaths i'm not talking about
hospitalizations i'm talking about cases
normally 45 million illnesses
how many cases do you think have been
reported of the from the flu this year
925
not 925 000
that would be that would be an amazingly
small not compared to 45 million right
it's a small number
not 925 million
uh 925 cases of the flu according to
johns hopkins the flu has basically been
eradicated this year
how did this happen
either there is widespread misdiagnosis
of things maybe that were flu and
they're diagnosed as covid maybe they're
covered the diagnosis flew maybe
who knows so that's one and now that's a
big claim i'm not saying there's
evidence for that claim
or you can say that the mitigation this
is what the left is saying they're
saying the mitigation measures that we
put in place for covid
stopped the spread of the flu so no
surprise here of course we got rid of
the flu
because we're all washing our hands and
wearing the stupid masks and we're all
social distancing to use the orwellian
phrase and that's that's why there's no
flu okay that would make sense except
at the same time that you're telling me
that all the mitigation measures
stop the flu you're telling me that they
utterly failed to stop the coronavirus
so which is it are they really i guess
they could be dif it seems to me
kind of incoherent seems to me
just like every other aspect of the
public health response to the
coronavirus
that they are just making this up as
they go along and they are contradicting
themselves
sometimes day by day like dr fauci who
says don't wear masks masks are terrible
they don't do anything then two seconds
later he says yeah you should have to
you have to wear masks
you must wear masks and then he's caught
on camera not wearing masks even though
he's next to
a lot of people then it doesn't matter
changes day by day sometimes it changes
within the very same breath while
they're explaining the flu thing away
but let's just let's just take it as it
is with the flu
let's say that we can get rid of the flu
every single year if we do all this
stuff where the stupid masks and social
distance quote unquote and don't have
thanksgiving and okay i don't want to do
that
i would rather get the flu than do
all of this inhuman anti-constitutional
nonsense that we've been doing for over
almost a year now our freedom
and our traditions and our way of life
are worth more than not getting the flu
and i think this is true of the woofloo
too i think this is true as you know i
i wear a mask if i have to go on an
airplane because that's the one
the one place where they say you can't
you cannot do this if you don't have a
mask on
and so i do it in cases where i think
it's more important that i go
fly be able to give a speech be able to
go to a political event be able to talk
about how dumb the masks are
i'm making up that calculation i think
it's worth it but otherwise you know i
ignore all this stuff and i
practically fringe kiss people when i
meet them on the street
so i would rather do that
than not get the virus i'm just not that
afraid i'm taking
my risk into account i understand
there's some risk so don't
i'm not saying i'm invincible but i'm
just taking risk into account
really what this is what the whole covid
lockdown thing has been
what some statesmen are calling the rate
the reset
building back better it's just the green
new deal by the back door
right it's just the same
massive political and social upheaval
that the left has wanted for
decades and decades and decades they're
just getting it this way instead of the
other way
back in the 70s they said that we're
heading to a new ice age
global cooling is about to take over the
world and that's why you need to give us
a lot of power and we need to
depopulate the earth and i mean this is
this is well known there were
books there were very prominent written
about this and you've got very prominent
public figures
that are still talking about why we need
to depopulate why we need to
increase access to abortion we need to
increase contraception we need to have
fewer
children i'm talking about people like
bill gates and al gore given speeches on
this very topic
so in the 70s they said it's because of
global cooling then like five seconds
later they said no it's actually because
of global warming
you say oh good well it sounds like
cooling cooling's not a big issue now
we're all good right they said no
we have to do all the same stuff that we
asked for before more much more
government power
much less control of private property
have fewer children live less
do less you say wait it's you're telling
me that for the opposite problem
we have the exact same slate of
solutions they say yes then
when the warming kind of peters out for
a little bit they say okay it's actually
climate change
so climate will climb it's always
changing yeah well it's climate change
anyway you've got to do all that same
stuff
say okay well it seems a little strange
to me then they say yeah and actually
since you're not going to give us the
green new deal um and people don't
really care about the global warming
stuff and they're not afraid of the sun
monster
it's actually the virus yeah there's a
virus you know and that's why you got to
give us all the same stuff
we have to much more government control
over the economy and we need to
uh rebuild lots of edifices in this
country and we can't have that many kids
and we've got
all the same stuff massive
redistribution of wealth you say hold on
i could sort of follow when you said it
was one weather problem and another
weather problem and you give me the same
answer but how come now it's a virus and
you're giving me the same slate of
answers
the reason for this is that these
extremely progressive policies are part
of a
an entire politico-religious worldview
this worldview was summed up by no less
an intellect
last night than mark ruffalo at the zoom
golden globe awards i did not know that
the golden globe awards were going on
until i saw this stupid mark ruffalo
headline trending
they didn't really hold the golden
globes this was this actually was just
on zoom these people just zoomed in from
their
homes and accepted the award on a little
tiny screen hepatic as that
and ruffalo one of the most insufferable
people in hollywood decided to
use his acceptance to
give a theological diatribe
about our filial relationship
to the earth we have a dying mother just
like the mother in our story
she's mother earth and we must come to
balance with her
and honor her and she'll heal too
so let's be courageous together guys and
let's
let's turn let's turn the page on the
cruel past of this nation
the good news is inclusion and justice
and care for mother earth is breaking
out
everywhere the godly light of decency
is breaking through the hideous
dark storm we've been living through we
are all in this together we are the ones
we've been waiting for so let's do this
now i love you
oh where to begin first of all
our mother the earth
the earth is not my mother the earth is
a rock floating in space
that i like very much i really i love
the earth
i think it's great it provides a very
nice home for me
the earth is not my mother when people
say the earth
is our mother they are espousing a
religious point of view just as i might
say that my mother is the holy church
just as i might say in another sense
that my mother is
mary the mother of god just as i might
say that
so too some some crazy lib might say
that the earth is our mother
if the earth is our mother we have a
filial responsibility to her
and on the other side of that if the if
we are the children of the earth
then we're just kind of like dirt right
that's all that's kind of all we are
we don't really have the higher
spiritual faculties
that say christianity or even other
theistic religions
would put on us but the religious way
he's talking is even more explicit he
says
he keeps coming back he says the good
news is
inclusion and diversity the good news is
the good news is the good news is the
gospel
okay when when people who don't have
this kooky
lib religion when people who have like
who are christians
say the good news is what's the good
news the good news is that the earth
i'm not the child of a rock that uh the
i'm actually
uh a child of god i'm a man made in the
image of god
uh god sends his only begotten son
christ to die for us and and uh we can
be part of the body of christ and christ
can live in us and
redeem mankind uh if we
if we accept him through faith and we
under
sort of understand this kind of or we
grant this kind of
world view this relationship of us
to the son of god who is god in the
triune god in the godhead
and therefore we have a special
relationship to creation and to the
creator
okay right that's one version of the
good news
if you're a christian but if you don't
believe any of that stuff
then what is the good news is diversity
and equity and inclusion
which which is treated as a religion
there's something really really spooky
though i do need to
touch on this there's a very famous
priest by the name of father james
martin
he's a jesuit who is known for making
statements that
people widely interpret to be heretical
and but he's very very popular
especially with liberals i think
i think he spoke at the democratic
national convention i know he's friends
with very high profile
liberals and he it would seem to me
you know from my position in the laity
seems to often contradict or at least
scandalize and confuse important aspects
of the faith
so father james martin posted yesterday
quote preaching for the second sunday of
lent vicki mcbride reflects on
everything that changed
last lent and offers a reflection on
allowing god to reveal
herself to us
so for as progressive as father martin
is he seems not to respect
god's preferred pronouns god is pretty
clear about which pronouns he prefers
you know the our father for instance
uh the incarnation of the second person
of the trinity
in as a man named jesus
it's pretty clear to me that god uses
then
the bible is replete with other examples
of this and a very famous priest
is now referring to god as her and
he's now to sort of justify it he's
invoking some sort of mystical visions
of people like julian of norwich or
some other people but james martin is
going much much further
father martin is is making claims here
that
would seem uh very contrary to the
church teaching
i i hope that bishops and i pray that
bishops would be able to summon the
courage
and the compassion to educate father
martin and so many other people who are
so confused
even within the church
it's very difficult to educate ourselves
these days because
we're not being permitted to read great
works
or important works we know that in
classrooms
great books are being removed from the
classroom they're being removed from
curricula
either because they're politically
incorrect or because they were written
by that dread character the red
the dead white man and so instead
we're getting kind of lower quality
modern books
pushing ridiculous theories but it's not
just in the classroom
amazon is banning books
now we we know that they were banning
our friend ryan t anderson's book
when harry became sally great title
the reason they did this and they've now
sort of admitted it is they've removed
an
exception for books they would remove
politically incorrect objects from
amazon in the past
especially when a scandal would come up
but they kept books there they didn't
want to be seen as banning books
now now they're doing that they're
they're uh not going to sell
they say quote we won't sell certain
content including content that we
determine is hate speech
promotes the abuse or sexual
exploitation of children contains
pornography glorifies rape or pedophilia
advocates terrorism or other material
that we deem inappropriate or offensive
uh all you need to pay attention to here
though
is the hate speech part because
that's going to be used you know it is
being used specifically to target
perfectly anodyne conservative books i
have a book coming out
in june it is currently listed on amazon
it's called speechless controlling words
controlling minds
if they got rid of ryan anderson's book
they they will get rid of my book
there is no logical reason why they
wouldn't if they're willing to get rid
of anderson's book
so i would encourage you to pre-order it
now while you still can i'm not saying
this just
to sell books so i'd like to do that i'm
saying this because i would like
this book to get out there i think it
actually takes on this this very issue
and i do suspect it's going to be
suppressed by the big tech company so
anyway
just a quick plug to order while you
still can
it's obviously not evenly applied you
can still order mineconf on
on amazon right now you can order books
by hitler but you can't order
mainstream american conservative books
the reason for this is that mineconf
doesn't pose any problem to the dominant
liberal regime in america
nobody is going out and really i mean
having like three people
no huge number of people are going out
buying mineconf
and reading it and saying oh yes now i'm
going to transform my views and become
a nazi generally speaking the people who
are reading mineconf
are reading it for historical and
scholarly purposes make sense
or if they're reading it because they
have an affinity for hitler then you
know they've already got the affinity
if you're searching out mind conf
because you really like hitler then
mineconf is not going to convince you to
like hitler anymore
that's not the same as a conservative
book there are people
who with these issues that are coming up
right now not not
dead issues like nazism but issues that
are still high right now like gender
ideology
you could pick up a conservative book
and change your mind and realize that
the narrative that the liberal regime
is pushing to you is not true and so
that that is why ryan anderson's book or
other conservative books too are much
more dangerous
to the dominant liberal establishment
than anything by
hitler or mussolini or whatever that
they actually don't really care about
that
because it doesn't threaten them this
is being called cancel culture i've told
you i don't think cancer culture is a
particularly helpful term
because i i don't i think it's a trap of
political correctness i think that
the trap that political correctness
leads us into is to believe that
when they overturn the old standards
with their new crazy left-wing standards
the only choices we have are either to
give in to the new standards or to issue
standards entirely and say okay well you
can say and do whatever you want
we don't believe anything i don't think
that's true i think that
yeah we we should watch what we say in
certain instances i think that we should
enforce laws against obscenity to
varying degrees i'm not saying
ban everything out right i'm just saying
we should in the american tradition of
free speech
discourage some of some offensive speech
that is actually offensive or that is
obscene or that is threatening or that
is seditious or
any of the other broad swats of speech
that in the american
tradition we have said is off limits i
think the only way that we're actually
going to
beat political correctness is by
recognizing that it's not a battle
between free speech and censorship
as the left wants to trick us into
believing it is
because then either way either way the
left wins right because
if we give in or we issue standards
entirely
either way the left gets to obliterate
the old standards we need to realize is
political correctness is actually
instead of a battle between free speech
and censorship
it's a battle between two competing sets
of standards the old moral codes and the
new speech codes
and we need to defend our substantive
moral vision
so i don't really use this term cancel
culture and
i'll give you an example of how cancel
culture though it's not
you know i don't really use it cancel
culture
can be a good thing if it supports a
conservative view
example of this is linkedin linkedin was
hosting that woca cola
be less white employee diversity
training thing remember that so
coca-cola
was accused of themselves putting out
this training what they actually did was
they
trained their employees to access this
other platform which was on linkedin
which included a training by robyn
d'angelo which said you need to be less
white
i think that's bad i think that's wrong
and i think they should get rid of it
and i don't think that coca-cola
employees should should watch that
i don't think they should have to watch
that i don't think coca-cola should be
even giving them access to watch that i
think it's just trash and it's terrible
for the country
and nobody benefits from it well
coca-cola gave it or i'm sorry rather
linkedin gave in
linkedin removed a racist diversity
training program
that told people to be less white isn't
that cancelled culture
isn't that censorship in a way kind of
but not really
it's just standards it's just finally
for once
we pressured corporate america to go
back to our good old standards
instead of embracing the new radical
wicked
politically correct standards that's a
good thing so when we use cancer culture
as just a
technical term you know it's fair people
are going to keep using it i'll probably
use it at some point too
but we need to remember that refers to
the specific
phenomenon of left wingers
destroying the lives and livelihoods of
conservatives because the conservatives
are
are uttering mainstream points of view
cancel culture
does not it cannot refer to the
consequences for anybody for saying or
doing anything
because conservatives traditionally and
i think still do believe
that there ought to be consequences for
saying and doing certain things nobody
thinks that if you wear the
swastika at your water cooler and start
screaming sig hile in the office
that you're somehow entitled to a job
well likewise nobody thinks that we need
to support
these vicious bigoted racist trainings
that say be
less white on linkedin no way
need to grow a spine we need to offer a
substantive
moral vision and i think if cpac showed
us anything it's that the gop
is still clamoring for that who can give
it to him
what's it going to look like in 2022 and
2024
we'll have to wait and see i'm michael
this the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt welsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show